normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government in a
cartoon from George alexopoulos which
has triggered many people and resulted
in uh some hot uh political debate you
have uh I don't know the names is is
this is this like Shane Dawson who who
knows who these people are it's like uh
Shane Dawson Dave Rubin and is that is
that P bu yep and so this is an image in
George alexop made showing uh famous
photos that he he made he drew versions
of where two gay men are holding babies
that they had through surrogacy and the
fourth panel is women wearing the uh um
what the handmaid's tail hand's tail
Garb and they're all pregnant giving
birth and he's making I we can all see
what his point is that basically these
men are all having kids with each other
and the women are being used as as
George Colin Carlin described it brood
mares for the state as it were this has
led to a lot of a very interesting
debate and uh the quartering you guys
know him you love him has absolutely
gone off about this saying two gay men
bought a child ripped it from their
birth mother to post selfies the child
will never know its mother it will grow
up with a guy who jerked off on his cat
and and geez and and he's referring to
Dawson Shane Dawson yeah right someone
responded Dave Ruben and Shane dos not
are not the same and the quartering said
they are people get give daveid pass
because he's a conservative I certainly
do not agree that Shane Dawson and Dave
Rubin are the same that I believe there
is Nuance in this but uh the quartering
put out a video he says a baby deserves
a mother and a father two gay men buying
an egg renting a woman paying a
laboratory to create human life is an
Abomination the child will never know
its mother uh and this is a very
interesting debate especially because uh
Shane Dawson is not is not Dave ruin and
uh uh however we had on this show with
liby for instance we've had very Fierce
debates over surrogacy and uh when when
this came up I was like I think we got
to talk about on the show because aside
from the fact you know the Cs put out a
video about it Keem Stars responded it's
generating generating a lot of drama and
it's it's directly targeting you know
people that we know and like I like Dave
Rubin he's a good dude so uh we we
actually got into this so I'm just going
to kick it off and the question
immediately is does this constitute
buying a child do I have to have do I
have to be part of this conversation no
I don't what
we'll give it to Phil Phil give us the
direct answer here we put Phil on the
spot I don't know I don't know that I I
I don't think that it that it
constitutes buying a child um but when
you get into the when when it is the
situation of just two gay guys going to
a woman saying hey will you get pregnant
and let us purchase the child from you
maybe it is I don't know um I don't I
think the fact that the ch
in the grand scheme of things the intent
is for the child to grow into adulthood
and take ownership of its own life so I
don't think so but again are we all just
very libertarian here and we're going to
be like if the kid has a good life
that's all that matters I I think it
also matters on the intentions here cuz
there are a lot of people who are doing
this for clout they're doing this for
attention they're doing this because
it's like yeah it's just kind of trendy
here and when it cames when it comes to
uh Shane uh Dawson there's a lot of
deprived Behavior there I did a report
on this for my members of lukan
filter.com cuz this is something that we
can't really get into on YouTube but
there are some very disturbing videos of
Shane Dawson with other children that
are extremely inappropriate uh I can't
even mention what they did here it's
sickening it's disgusting and this is
why a lot of people are having issue
with this because they're saying hey
this guy who did all these horrible
disgusting things including to other
children on camera and on video that was
absolutely inappropriate this guy's not
going to have his own children that he
paid for there's some serious questions
and concerns here and I and I understand
those concerns and questions now to
equate that to Dave ruin I don't know if
it's that if that's uh fair or not some
people say yes some people say no but
there are a lot of concerning statistics
when it comes to uh particularly uh gay
couples and uh the hurting of children
that I think are are worth looking at
and having a serious conversation on
that we can't have here I think that as
far as those things go like I was we
were talking about this earlier I think
as far as that kind of stuff goes there
is my opinion Falls similarly to the
opinion that I have about gun laws so
there's already laws against murder
there's already laws against uh
destruction of other people's property
so there there's no need to have gun
laws because there are laws against
mishandling a gun there are laws against
abusing children so I don't know that
you need to say we need to prevent gay
people from having you know from from
adopting because C they may you know
someone's making the argument that
they're more inin to that that is an
argument Jeremy uh the quaring has
brought up but it's not his principal
argument what's princip principal
argument being that a man and a woman
had a child the child was taken from the
mother in exchange for cash to be raised
by the by two men yeah so I I was I
guess referencing a moral question about
Jeremy saying that child should have
children should have a mother so I I
never you know me enough I don't play
the gay card cuz I just think it's very
very boring but I guess I'm the token
gay guy here who's also married um would
he have the same objection to like Alec
Baldwin who has a number of kids and
they had a number through surrogacy
because they wanted kids the same age
right I think they had one within this
year and she gave birth to one and they
surrogated the other so that they're
like well they're twins they're both
mine we just used someone else's womb
for the second one right a number of
straight couples use so so is it a gay
thing which it is and if is it's fine
there's a lot of people who don't like
gay people and don't think gay people
should either be married or and I will
have that conversation comfortably
because those are good conversations to
have so like let's talk if it's a gay
thing that's one thing if it's a
surrogacy thing that's another but I
don't know what his argument is because
I wonder if straight people would get
the same level of scrutiny like I said I
don't play the gay oh you're just doing
it cuz I hate that card but I do have to
ask otherwise they come after me so then
the question right that's why I live on
a farm with a lot of guns so they don't
they don't get tooo close hopefully G
are bad shots also as a general rule but
so so the question is in your example
they used uh you know Alec baldon's wife
uses her own eggs yeah and they do IVF
and another woman uh uh grows gestates
the child yes rent a womb right that's
what critics have called it renting out
a woman's body the difference being if
if a woman uh uh gives birth a child
that is biologically hers and then hands
it off to anyone I don't care if it's 2
gay men anybody in exchange in exchange
for
compensation is that buying a child and
then the question is if she's uh
carrying a child that is not genetically
hers but was uh done through IVF with
another person is she renting her body
like what what what is it what if a
woman had a hysterectomy and she can't
produce eggs but her husband wants to
have a baby that's biologically his so
they didn't just rent the womb they also
bought an egg on the market or went to
is that so with one one woman gives the
egg another woman gives the the uterus
this woman is going to be the mom there
are technically three women involved in
this baby we need to have Jeremy here
because there's a lot of questions a lot
question okay what what so if let's say
there's a let's say there's a woman and
uh she can't have kids she's incapable
and husband wants kids though but and
they want to be together and they want
to raise kids together so the husband
says we will find a surrogate and I will
have a child with her but it will be
ours to raay is the issue that it's the
wrong mother now because what the
quartering said is every child deserves
a mother well the child will have a
mother in this scenario is that still
wrong a lot of very interesting
questions that are being raised here
there's also another aspect here when
you look at uh the statistics when it
comes to children raised by mothers
comparably to children that are raised
by fathers as of course the data proves
that children raised by fathers are a
lot better off especially when it comes
to mental physical health and also
quality of life then of bo bo boys then
then of course the people raised by
mothers so are we going to be okay with
uh two mothers raising a a surrogate
child or are we going to have issue with
uh two dudes raising a child what's
going to be the best what's going to be
the the larger kind of issue to society
if we're going to be having this
discussion to the larger we generally
not going to have a problem with with
two women because women are the people
that are going to make the noise about
it and their their General General
consensus is women are better no matter
what the the data says women are always
going to say that women are better at
raising raising PE children than the
data doesn't support they don't they
don't care they're not
interested feelings over facts end
result of this is okay Ben Shapiro
growing growing humans in bags and pots
yeah that's coming that's coming yeah
that's it that's absolutely coming and
and that's why a lot of Americans are
are left in fertile and I think this is
going to be a bigger and bigger issue as
we go on mainly because sperm levels are
are going down the qualities of women's
eggs are going down people are not able
to have children I think a lot of this
is deliberate I think this is a eugenic
operation that is being carried out on
the American people on the people of the
western world who are unsuspecting of
this larger chemical biological warfare
that is being waged on them but I think
the endgame of all of this is to
essentially have pod babies is to to
have selective breeding is to have
Eugenics at the highest level where the
government says you now with your social
credit score have won one permission to
have a child we're going to take your
DNA here we're going to grow a baby out
of a bag or even you know better off you
know what no no no we're just going to
give you a hunter Biden baby because
that's the baby that deserves to live on
that's the baby that of course actually
is going to get a life especially when
you look at the larger kind of uh crazy
individuals that have a lot of power
that believe that there's too many
people in this world what better way to
control a people than by of course
getting rid of their fertility and then
selectively control their breeding
that's what's going to be happening
that's their end game that's what they
want to do the biggest problem I have
with that image that you put up Tim is
that there was really no reason for pea
judge to get in a hospital bed like that
was just weird why did you get in the
hospital bed like you didn't do anything
like and that was the photo like that
was their real photo they put on
bracelets and they got in the bed and
I'm like that's just awkward didn't
Shane Shane Dawson do the same thing
like what why why are you doing that I
think Shane Dawson and this other guy
did the same thing they went in the
hospital beds and they were acting tired
and like sleeping I mean cuz you didn't
you didn't really do do anything at all
other than spill into a cup which
someone super CH asking why is it
different if Dave or Shane did I'm like
well because Shane has a questionable
pass where he said very shocking things
did shocking things too did shocking
things and Dave Rubin is a very
successful uh well-off individual that I
happen to think is a good dude and and
so the question really becomes like I'm
not the arbit of morality I'm a bit too
libertarian for all of these people who
are like it shouldn't be done and my
attitude is simply I believe that Dave's
kids are going to be extremely
successful I believe that uh it is
substantially better that Dave and his
Husband raise children as opposed to
like a woke family threatening to harm
the child sterilize them or cause that
child great serious and serious harm I I
believe the kids that are going to uh
grow up with with with Dave are going to
have a great family and they're going to
have great opportunities I think the
biggest problem I have with this
scenario is that the women who would
likely become the surrogates probably
need the money and I don't like the fact
that we're creating a society where if
you are 24 and you need and it's and
it's a lot of money it's 50,000 75,000
plus all the medical expenses 100,000
whatever I'm sure if you're a Kardashian
it's probably a quarter of a million
because you probably sign a bunch of
legal work thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net see you all next
time